mo brooks was finally served in one of  the insurrection lawsuits in potentially  the most hilarious way possible  as you may or may not know to serve  someone with a lawsuit  often you have to physically hand that  to them and often people use process  servers and  in this particular case we have video of  when mo brooks's wife  was served with this particular lawsuit  the process server was trying to get a  hold of mo brooks or his wife  she was returning home the process  server followed her into the garage  attempted to serve her and then got back  in his cart  that point she appears to be incredibly  pissed she gets behind his car  ostensibly to get his license plate  number possibly to prevent him from  leaving  and then throws a hissy fit but that was  probably enough to effectuate service in  this particular lawsuit and yeah  sometimes that's what you had to do to  serve someone with a lawsuit so  you can see them in court